I'm a star see that Oh mal it feels like
only yesterday that we saw you stealing
candy from a baby and now you're helping
the gays get a chance at a better life
and risking yours in the process we
might be huge fans of you and your
friends but that's not the case for
everybody
like seriously mal can you have any more
enemies
Audrey uma Hades and dr. faciliate might
have a bone to pick with Maleficent's
daughter but that doesn't mean that the
descendants three cast doesn't get along
behind the scenes so that's my favorite
thing to watch it's just the process of
[Music]
keep watching to see some of the cutest
behind-the-scenes moments the stars of
d3 have to offer
boom-shaka-laka the descendents cast
knows how to rile themselves up before a
long day on set and director Kenny
Ortega loves seeing his team boom
Shakalaka Inc all over the place we love
this behind-the-scenes moment from the
d3 arrivals in rehearsals video everyone
looked so happy and in their element
hugs all around by now we all know that
the cast of descendants is one big happy
family they love and support each other
no matter what so we weren't surprised
to see how happy dub Cameron and the
rest of the cast was to reunite with
each other on set dub definitely had
more than enough hugs to go around
dancing dinosaur Cameron Boyce was
always quick to goof around with his
friends and make the most out of every
moment so when he found one of his cast
mates dressed up as a dinosaur in his
trailer he did what came naturally to
him he started dancing with the intruder
what a hilarious moment Jay and Doug
dancing the day away
who knew that booboo Stewart and Zackary
Gibson were such close friends in real
life while Doug and Jay might not have
the closest on-screen relationship they
have a total bromance brewing behind the
scenes coming director for Jay Pillsbury
in this d3 arrivals in rehearsals video
we get to see Jay and Doug dancing the
day away in each other's arms
it's Jane's birthday again Jane
celebrates her birthday in the new
descendents three movie but
unfortunately she doesn't get to bake
her cake and eat it too luckily it looks
like the d3 cast surprised Brenna D
amico for her birthday with the help of
the quiz me crew Brenna looks both
surprised and touched at the same time
Harry Gill and rent if you're a part of
the descendence crew there's a good
chance you grew up watching rent the
musical over and over again in this
behind-the-scenes clip we see Dylan play
fair and Thomas Dougherty's singing
along to the rent song seasons of love
dub cameron posted this video on her
snapchat this golden moment just had to
be shared with the world the sing and
dance
and make a Disney movie it's really a
fine job do the wave
Disney descendants recently posted a
first day on set video and we couldn't
help but notice some super adorable
moments in this video we see Cameron
Chyna
Thomas boo-booed of Sofia and Jada
holding hands and doing the wave we love
how close the d3 cast is and how they're
always doing group activities to raise
their spirits directors can bust moves -
Kenny Ortega is a staple in the Disney
Channel industry he's a producer
director and choreographer although he
tends to instruct his actors on how to
dance he's been known to bust a move or
two as well in this scene we see Kenny
spinning Sophia around while the rest of
the cast watches and laughs from the
sidelines
hey boo boo it's been years since the
cast of descendants first got together
so it's safe to say that they're super
close in this clip we see booboo Stewart
china anne mcclain and Sarah Jeffery
riding around in a van and having a
great time
Chyna and Sarah Shara laughs when booboo
is unable to mimic the strange sound
coming out of China's mouth okay
play-fighting dove Cameron and booboo
Stewart have been close friends ever
since they met on the set of the first
ascendance film so we're not surprised
to find them play fighting behind the
scenes in this clip dub pretends to hit
boo-boo and he goes down without a fight
Bob takes things a step further by
stepping on him and claiming her victory
work it Jay
in this whole area is fine the scenes
moment we see booboo and Cameron goofing
around on set Cameron is holding his
phone out and filming booboo as he walks
down a make-believe catwalk
Cameron is giving booboo some words of
encouragement and they totally pay off
just look at Boo Boo's face he's working
every single angle two evils are better
than one it's no secret that uma and
Audrey have a lot in common mal will
fall so we're not too surprised to find
out that the actresses are super close
in real life check out this little clip
from the first day on set
yo Sarah and Chyna look like total BFFs
what an adorable moment to capture on
camera
Cameron making everyone smile Cameron
Boyce was truly one of the brightest
souls of all time and he loved making
his loved ones laugh out loud
he was always busting moves and putting
smiles on his friends faces we love this
video because it shows us how carefree
and funny he truly was dylan group hug
here's something we don't see every day
a villain group hug check out this clip
of dr. facili AJ Edie and Carlos hugging
it out now hugging her fans children
tweens teens and adults are all fans of
dub Cameron and her on-screen character
mouth in this video we see mal embracing
her fans and spreading some love now
that is a special moment if you could be
the child of any Disney villain who
would it be
tell us in the comments and don't forget
to hit that subscribe button and give
this video a big thumbs up thank you for
watching the things we'll catch you
later
[Music]